drake bell just revealed he's married
and has a son you've really grown up
in this industry for you what was the
secret to
really coming out the other side um you
know always just paying attention to and
being focused on the craft really
the 35 year old nickelodeon actor took
to twitter to reveal he's married
and has a child amid his recent legal
woes
bell who's been calling himself drake
campana since 2020
tweeted the news in spanish the
translated message reads quote
in response to various rumors that are
incorrect i have been married for almost
three years
and we are blessed to be the parents of
a wonderful son
thank you very much to all my fans
around the world for your good wishes
belle's statement comes after he was
spotted with his wife janet von
schmeling
who he's been romantically linked to for
the past few years
and a baby stroller at disneyland i have
a girlfriend she's pretty rad
she is in the industry uh she was
actually just on this cool little
snapchat uh show called uh snapped for
uh buzzfeed but yeah she's you know
she's
in the industry she's rocking it trying
back in 2017
bell opened up about his now wife to et
and revealed how they met just mutual
friends i was
uh i was a friend of mine
his daughter uh was out visiting
and then she was friends and we were all
just hanging out and
i was like hey you're really cool she
thought i was pretty cool too
but when asked if his lady inspires any
of his music
he played coy everyone in in my life
inspires my music i don't think
that i you know there's not one specific
love song i've written that i'd be like
oh that was about her you know
bell's family news comes on the heels of
his latest
legal woes last month the actor and
musician pleaded guilty to two criminal
counts of attempted
endangering children and disseminating
matter harmful to juveniles
the charges are related to a girl who
claims she met him online and attended
one of his concerts in cleveland in 2017
when she was 15 years old bell's
attorney told et that it will be
revealed at the sentencing scheduled for
july 12th
quote why mr bell chose to enter today's
plea
the former drake and josh starr
previously pleaded
not guilty to the charges earlier this
month when he appeared in court in ohio
and posted a 2 500 bond
ordering him to have no contact with his
alleged victim
according to court documents obtained by
et the alleged incident happened on
december 1
2017 in ohio bell was indicted
on may 21 2021
[Music]